kommen wir zu unserem außen reporter
karl öllinger
ich habe mir nicht gesagt wo er ist die
ob keine ahnung was er macht was den
vorteil hat dass er mir nie vorher schon
aufbringen muss also ich denke mal für
ihn hätte die sommerpause ruhig länger
dauern können kralinger können sie mich
hören lauter und deutlicher wird um
endlich endlich darf ich sie auch wieder
den allein ihre aura beflügelt mich
günter grünwald das ist gehen sie hatte
trainer gehen sie hat die sommerpause
hätte keine sekunde länger dauern dürfen
holliger das gibt's nicht das gleiche
hobby gerade auch über sie gesagt
wirklich ich ja vielleicht das nicht mit
diesen worten aber ähnliche buchstaben
waren dabei
also wo sind sie ja gerade um was geht
und was geht so etwas gewöhnt einmalig
dieser humor den kann man mich kopieren
es geht um das größte volksfest dieser
erde dass hier in kürze wieder seine
pforten öffnet und ich bin heiß wie ein
halbes hendl wie ein ganzes hin lehrerin
war es geht ums oktoberfest herr
kralinger lasst uns die mrt von ihrem
kopf machen da wird man feststellen dass
man ins gehirn geschissen hat versteh
ich und muss runter trinken geniale idee
her über das mache ich sofort habe ich
war ja ja entschuldigen sie wenn ich das
jetzt so deutlich frage herr gerlinger
aber sang sie ein genie herr grünewald
nein soweit würde ich nicht gehen ich
bin lediglich ein mann der nicht alles
akzeptiert was stimmt er träumt wo
andere aufgeben der hinterfragt was
andere einfach so hinnehmen und deswegen
er übertrage ich sie nur weil die ganze
welt denkt dass das oktoberfest abgesagt
ist muss es deswegen stimmen darauf dass
mein arsch verwenden
naja aber wie auch immer herr grimm hat
ich bin mir sicher die kommen gleich wer
kommt gleich die helfer die helfer vom
weihnachtsmann oder wo es für helfer
meinen sie
nein nicht die helfer die aufbauhelfer
hierher grünwald hier gleich alles
aufbauen
die geisterbahn die zelte den fünf
loopings und das zuckerwatte staatlicher
grün und ich liebe zuckerwatte kralinger
lesen sie es von meinen lippen
es gibt dieses jahr kein oktoberfest
doch der gewalt doch das gibt es ich bin
mir sicher die kommen jeden moment jeden
moment kommentiert und dann dann kommt
der bürgermeister und der begrüßt nicht
persönlich und dann gibt er seinen
anzahl vergrößert und ich darf an sagt
ich darf als horst heidbrink ich auch
noch eine dritte hat über trollinger
karl galimow sie ist die keine wiesen
und wird zur gänze ruhr sie dämlicher
trottel
ich weise sie ihren augen nicht als ich
gehofft 670 hiermit hier weil ich genau
wie rewe genau hier ist mein platz im
himmel dabei und diese tischwäsche seit
ewigkeiten familie besitzt den hat mein
uropa im jahre 1860 bei der
christbaumversteigerung auf der ersten
weihnachtstag über die sekretärin
gesteigert und zeitlich gehört dass
dieser platz wird kommt so ein saublödes
näheres darüber dass alles wegnehmen das
ist doch das ist doch das ist unfair
ja da haben schon recht ja gerade jetzt
beruhigen sie sich erst einmal wieder
und dann gehen sie heim und machen sie
ein feierabendbier auf und komme es erst
einmal runter und vorher games
vielleicht zurück ins studio
angeblich ist es dem kind studieren ja
ja unser außen reporter karl reidinger
[Applaus]